so what do you do here at Khan Academy I
am the finance assistants so I take care
of Finance II type things which includes
the accounting the bookkeeping and then
generating reports and managing benefits
and just overviewing like the accounts
and stuff like that what does that mean
like a cow you know what we're
not-for-profit what are additional
business why is there finance at Khan
Academy yeah so like any organization
there's you know it's just about any
organization you can think of choirs
money to run it and also to in order to
just keep things going like the pay for
you know rent and keep the lights on
that sort of thing so there are accounts
that we have where we keep this money
that we have to spend on these expenses
and so looking at that making sure that
you know their money's going to the
right spots things like that or what I
do when looking at it they towns what's
what's your day-to-day like make it make
it tangible for us okay so the
day-to-day for me like this may be a
typical day there will be some checks
that come in people or very supportive
Khan Academy so we'll send in some kind
of you know a physical handwritten check
and then I go to the bank and deposit
that into accounts and then for the rest
of the day maybe I'll look at inputting
new hires and making sure they're in
payroll in the payroll system so that
the next time that payroll comes around
they get paid for doing the the Glary
important we all appreciate that yeah
that's how paychecks get dispersed but
yeah yeah yeah the payroll so things
like that I also take care of and then
making sure that like the the benefits
plans that people have like medical
insurance and things like that they
those are those services were getting
pay and then people are input into those
services so that the service know is
that we need to cover this person and
that sort of thing and then there will
also be reconciling the accounts like
making looking through like the list of
the expenses we pay the checks we've
written and make seen making sure that
those are legitimate like checks we
wrote and that someone from the
organization actually made that
expensive is not really like fraud or
anything like that right so there's a
little
kind of a accountability cuz yeah sure
that yeah I'll be up and up yeah
everything they make sure that that you
know we that there was someone from the
organization that decided to make an
expense or pay for a service or
something like that and that's part of
making sure that the accounts are as it
should be it and that no one's like
someone no one's found their way into
the account by a secret tunnel or
something like them able to siphon money
and and what were you doing before
joining relatively when did you join I
joined about five months ago yeah join
very recently before this I was an
intern at Kiva org which is another
nonprofit in the Bay Area and I was
doing financial analysis and that sort
of thing for them what's your background
what did you what do you what did you
study in college to become this well I
may be for this role I have sort of an
untraditional background because I
studied the arts and in college and did
things like filmmaking in theatre and I
still do theatre now and eventually I
got into an MBA program and started
studying finance and things like
accounting and so I was always
passionate about like like arts and an
education and that sort of thing and
then I eventually grew into wanting to
do finance for like nonprofits and that
sort of thing for like with finance in
terms of a mission doing finance for for
admission is something that I was very
passionate about and so how did you find
your way to Khan Academy and why did you
join this band of somewhat crazy people
it is a band of crazy people I was but
how I found Khan Academy was well I've
known about Khan Academy for a long time
actually seeing like your interviews on
the television and whatnot and and
hearing about the stories from but even
back when I was in San Diego and so it's
always been on my mind like this Khan
Academy and so when I finally saw there
was an opening I decided this is this to
me it seems like a great place that I'd
want to be let's see if they feel the
same way and so I decided to apply them
meaning the people meaning
everyone here it just kind of reaffirmed
that for me that there's some really
really great people here and that the
mission is always like on people's minds
and and there's such connection to the
mission also I just this morning I was
at PA Walsh and I was a wolf
yeah the pea Walsh elementary in Morgan
Hill and and and we was with the people
from Google and handing them their their
their check for $15,000 in technology
because this learns for yeah cause he
learns from competition and they they
had incredible hustle at this this
measure of people how much effort there
pretty much yeah so these people put in
this these these students put incredible
effort into this learn storm competition
that we had in the Bay Area and so they
were rewarded by by Google with this
this incredible ly generous check for
$15,000 to spend on technology for their
school and so and it's great to see all
the kids so excited and and and see like
the faculty that are just so passionate
about seeing the kids excited it's just
such a great way to be in touch with the
mission I think ya on the ground like
how how how the Khan Academy and whatnot
it's it's it's impact is actually
affecting people real people what's what
surprised you most in the last five
months what has surprised me most I
think I am surprised how I think I'm
surprised just how close people are in
this organization I feel like everyone
seems to basically talk to everyone and
that's that's one of those things where
people I feel like they're connected to
the different parts of the everything
that's going on I mean I might not know
exactly like what the developers doing
or and that sort of thing but they
constantly have these these developers
stand-ups and constantly around them
like during lunch time and they're
talking about different issues they're
working through and different thought
experiments they have and it's just it's
fascinating to be part of a culture
that's constantly thinking up new
problems and trying to solve them and
sort of like pushing the envelope in
that way
and so it's been very fascinating and
very very enriching to be part of an
organization that's that's constantly
you know both in touch with people that
are that are users and learners in touch
with the the product itself and how
aggregate people are reacting to the to
the product and also in touch with each
other across different departments and
then being able to be to just have that
that that sort of sense of like oh or
these are this is sort of a software
development world this is sort of a
community partnerships world this is
this is a product world and and just
having all these worlds come together
and and be such a tight-knit group is
something that I've found really amazing
ya know it's yeah I consider myself
pretty lucky as well to be working with
you and the rest of the team yeah yeah
very lucky very lucky to be here oh
thank you yeah